I started working on natural language
processing with a goal to be able to
detect patterns in text so for example
if people explained why they voted for
one candidate versus someone else what
were the sort of General themes that
might come out of this and so something
like topic models was one area that I
worked and that's just asking this
question like what words simply tend to
co-occur with each other so for example
if we were to take each speaker what
they're saying and ask like all right
what are the different topics that
they're talking about I might talk a
little bit more about some of the
algorithms maybe some of the business
models Vijay might talk a little bit
about some of the more technical things
of how they work etc but it was really
about how words just tend to co-occur
together or something like sentiment
analysis which was saying hey like I
know which words are negative and which
words are positive and let's just get a
general sense of the room like are
people feeling good or not and I should
say
I got a lot of citations for developing
you know software packages that did this
sort of stuff my colleague Gary King has
been a leader in this area as well just
providing these sorts of tools so then
you started to see more advanced things
come up people started to do research on
something called word embeddings and
this is this idea that maybe we can
figure out like words that are share a
semantic meaning even though they're
different from each other so for example
how does an algorithm know that
Massachusetts is similar to New York
well they're similar because they're
both a state and so companies and
researchers started to do work training
models to to figure that out and then
imagine a version of that where we're
able to
um do the same thing not for words but
for whole sentences or whole documents
and so there's a lot of really great
work um that happen there and again you
know this was stuff that as a researcher
a white collar job I guess um you know I
was able to have some impact
but now we're in a whole other world
right
um we're in this world of multi-purpose
generative AI
um here we're talking about text but as
Latonya and others Illustrated here
we're we're doing things a lot
differently so sentence completion now
we had a version of that earlier or
style editing all right like Dustin
don't write in the passive voice right
but the flexibility is just you know
transformed so now it's you know a high
write code in language X to do y or
better yet here's some code in some
language now translate it for me uh to
some other language or here's 50 000
pages of documents that I've collected
and some say sort of legal Discovery
process
um I want you the algorithm to summarize
coherently or even be able to have
conversations and the the sort of where
this is taken research is going in all
sorts of new and fascinating uh uh
directions